and my guest with me here in the studio
is the General Secretary of the FDA
Union and that's Dave Penman hi Davis
good morning thanks for joining us what
have you heard
um well what's quite clear is the
credible complaints uh from a number of
government departments about Dominic
Rabb just like there were credible
complaints about Gavin Williamson before
it and what's quite clear is that civil
servants do not have confidence in the
current process for raising complaints
against ministers the only way they can
raise a complaint is through the
ministerial code which requires not only
the prime minister to consent in
investigation taking place but the prime
minister is the ultimate Arbiter on that
complaint as well and as we saw with the
pretty Patel complaint despite evidence
of bullying he refused to acknowledge
that she'd breached the ministerial code
so there's no real way that civil
servants feel they can raise complaints
which is why this as a sort of situation
we're facing with speculations coming
out into the public rather than being
dealt with through an effective
complaints process let's let's go back
to that but let me just ask you in a bit
more detail what sort of complaints have
you heard about because the letter that
you wrote to the Prime Minister you
didn't even name Dominic Robb did you no
because it's not just about Dominic Rabb
um we've had complaints raised with us
about a number of ministers over many
years this is a system that's not
effective in dealing with uh bullying by
ministers as we saw in Parliament where
you have a system that people don't have
confidence in they simply will not raise
formal complaints so when number 10 say
there are no formal complaints being
raised the right but that doesn't mean
that concerns aren't being raised by
civil servants and even the permanent
secretary in the government Department
um has admitted that his behavior was
tantamount to bullying so we've got a
broken system just now so rather than
concentrating on Dominic Rob or Gavin
Williamson we want the prime minister to
reform the entire system for dealing
with complaints against ministers as I
said I do want to come on to that but
um tell me about specific complaints
that you've heard about about Dominic I
don't want to get into that because it's
not because it's not the forum for it
our whole point is what we shouldn't be
doing it's not fair to donate Robin it's
not 30 civil service it's better to the
public if they if you know if we've got
people who are allegedly bullying in in
positions of high office they're civil
so they're public servants we should
know about it but we should know and
ministers should have an effective way
to either have their name cleared or for
those investigations to be concluded and
to face the consequences if they've been
building what we don't think is
appropriate is that accusations are
bandied about in the media that that's
the only way that essentially civil
servants can raise these now because the
internal process isn't working no I
understand that and that's why I'm
pushing you on it if I may please Mr
Penman because the Prime Minister
disagrees with you who says that there
is no evidence that there's been
bullying no he doesn't he says there's
no formal complaints and that's the
point people have no confidence in
raising a formal complaint a formal
complaint would require the prime
minister to consent investigation and
there isn't even anyone just now who
could conduct that investigation since
June we haven't had an independent
advisor on Minister's interests the
cabinet secretaries made clear civil
servants can't investigate ministers so
there isn't even anyone to investigate a
complaint whether that was a dominant
Rob or whether that was a new complaint
about another Minister this is not a
system that's fit for purpose so why
don't your members make a formal
complaint well we saw what happened when
when they raised the formal complaint
you know when complaints were raised
about pretty Patel the Prime Minister
sat on that report for six months and
then prime minister of course it has a
different prime minister and then
um despite the evidence that she had
bullied civil servants the Prime
Minister refused to accept that refused
to say that she did hasn't done that and
he has acted quickly once was a formal
complaint about Gavin Williamson he
actually quickly and he's not there
that's that's all good and well but he
still hasn't done so so we are in a
situation where the only way that a
complaint could be raised a bit uh Gavin
sorry governments and or Dominic RAB as
if the prime minister degrees the prime
minister at this point in time could
conduct an initiate an investigation
into Dominic Robb to clean his name he
isn't doing so instead of that we have
this endless speculation about ministers
and civil servants have no confidence in
the current process it shouldn't be up
to the whim of a prime minister about
about whether to support his political
allies on whether an investigation is
conducted into bullying I suggest you
know that this prime minister we heard a
formal complaint about bullying would
say no he's my mate so I'm not listening
I don't know but that's been the
experience in the past the prime
ministers inevitably and that's not with
this one well what's the test of of
relation I just know it's the government
um is that an investigation
anti-government Gavin Williamson so his
uh resignation essentially means there
won't be an investigation so we actually
have an independent process in
Parliament that even though people
resign and leave Parliament it still
concludes it still brings a conclusion
and a potential punishment in when it
comes to ministers if they design they
go off essentially scot-free and they're
free to come back into a cabin at a
later date the whole system just doesn't
work when it comes to protecting civil
servants from the conduct of ministers
it's only a few ministers it's not it's
not the entire cabinet it's not the
majority but they're all now tainted by
this because no one has confidence in
the system and even if the as we saw
with the pretty patella fair that
there's a conclusion from it people
don't actually believe it as I said that
was a different prime minister a
different era Rishi soon access that
he's wiping the Slate clean are there
other
ministers or cabinet ministers that your
members feel have behaved
inappropriately toward them serving
ministers there are yes we've had many I
I don't want to go into speculation of
numbers or complaints it's not
speculation I mean I'm just asking you
how many no because you must know people
people raise and concerns with us they
haven't been investigated that's only
one side of a story so I'm not going to
come here and start finding about
numbers or accusations as a result the
whole point about this is we don't have
a process for dealing with this
effectively it's not fair on ministers
and it's not fair on civil servants that
the only way that these sorts of
accusations end up coming out is
speculation in the Press
so
just to be clear your members are
telling you or not potentially you
directly but but your colleagues who are
coming to you to say that there are
several other ministers in Rishi sunax
government who have behaved
inappropriately towards them yes
but you can't tell me how many I'm I'm
not going to go into speculate how many
that's that's pretty can you give me an
idea of what sort of behavior we're
talking about is it bullying yeah most
most of what comes to us as an
appropriate behavior in terms of
ministers whether it's uh was in The
Temper shouting getting frustrated
governments a tough place to work for
both for civil servants and ministers
they know that but at times that
behavior can then Verge into what people
would characterize as bullying and just
like any other workplace that needs an
effective mechanism to address it and
that's not what we have but this is a
conscious this is not your members are
coming to you because they feel they
can't do anything else yeah because they
have no confidence what impact is it
having on them well it blights careers
people end up leaving the job or or
leaving the post that they're in if you
imagine you're a civil servant to work
with ministers who work at the heart of
government it's actually the Pinnacle of
your career that's what you've wanted to
do you want to work in public service
and work close with ministers and help
deliver the government's agenda so for
those who have to leave because that's
the only choice that they've got they
either put up with that behavior or they
leave it's it's hugely damaging to their
careers and of course to their lives
because bullying can have a huge impact
in people's lives and how do you help
them how do you support them through
that well we can support them in terms
of giving them advice about how to deal
with it whether that's a formal
complaint informally broker and getting
another job moving outside of the area
that's sometimes the only option you
know that's the difficulty because it's
more difficult to move a minister than
it is to move in a civil servant
um sometimes that's that's just what
happens and people recognize it but it
can be hugely damaging to individuals of
course I completely get that but just to
clarify it's not just Dominic Robb that
there that there are issues with which
is why you've not named names in the
letter that you've written to the Prime
Minister there are other high-profile
ministers who in your opinion as a union
leader are bullying civil servants and
the prime minister is doing nothing
about it what I'm seeing is that there
are concerns raised about a number of
minutes so that's essentially a constant
in government it's not just about this
government it's every government you
know there that you know there are
dozens of ministers and and stressful
situations and so at any point in time
you're inevitably going to have a
situation where there are concerns
raised about the conduct of ministers
that's why what we're seeing is this
isn't just about Dominic rabbits not
just about Gavin Williams and it's about
the entire system that deals with this
and if you don't have an effective
system for dealing with that sort of
behavior it almost encourages it and and
to what extent do you have some sympathy
for those government ministers who were
in the middle of a war in Europe we've
got a cost of living crisis there's been
turmoil
um over the last six months or so and
they are also up against it absolutely
others are the civil servants that
support them
um loyally and serve government I mean
as I say civil servants who work closely
with ministers are not shrinking
violence they know they've been working
at the heart of government they have to
deal with all of the crises that
ministers have to deal with as well but
they expect to be treated with dignity
and respect and they expect if if
ministers don't do that there would be
an effective effective system for
dealing with it could you talk to you
thank you very much Jenny for joining us
much appreciated thank you